more than three months after a
fifteen-year-old quan charles died in
louisiana one of the last people to see
him alive is now under arrest
janet irvin faces a felony charge of
failure to report a missing child along
with contributing to the delinquency of
a minor
now video shows urban picking up kawan
from his father's home this was on
october 30th the day his parents
reported him missing
irvin has told the family's
investigators that kawan
did drugs at her home then left
claiming he was going to kill himself
his body was found four days later in
ankle deep water and sugar
in a sugar cane ditch the autopsy and
toxicology report shows that he drowned
with a small amount of alcohol
and thc in his system the local sheriff
says the death investigation is ongoing
the charles family attorney says he
expects people will start coming forward
to explain how kawan died i'm confident
that my office
has put together an extremely strong
case against mrs irvin
we believe that other folks that have
information
now will see the walls closing in and i
believe
either from guilt or self-preservation
will begin to talk
now we have been unable to reach urban
for comment on this story
her bail has not been set and she is
still in custody at this hour
remember we covered this story from the
very beginning it was troubling from the
very start
and now to hear that she told his
family's attorneys that
she did drugs with him and her son and
quran and then left
and he claimed he was going to kill
himself you didn't call the family you
don't call the police and now you're the
last person
it's some the story is there's something
very smelly about the story and i hope
the family is right when they say maybe
more people come forward
because people know more to this story
than what we're hearing right yeah
that's true